all right last question every single
person gets asked you answered however
you want
end of 2021 bitcoin price prediction
what do you got for us
i think we revisit and go through the
highs again um
the only thing that has me concerned is
everybody's made the assumption
um you know i'll stick with that but
here but the one thing i would say and i
i'm spending a lot of time talking to
institutions about this i'm on my way
uh to the uae uh in the middle east on
september 3rd over labor day weekend
this topic will definitely come up
um everybody's assuming we're marching
towards the esg resolution i know a lot
of people that on coin now don't care
about it but it's the incremental buyer
that cares about it
and and i think every and they're making
assumption in the next 24 months will
resolve this problem
if you want to see bitcoin crack that
hundred thousand we got to have a
solution and this is only my opinion
nobody else is okay i'm not putting it
out there anywhere else when i see that
larry think letter with the word bitcoin
innocent in there when he writes and
says i've you know i'm okay with bitcoin
mine sustainably
that's when you see the 100k price
put your seatbelt on then
yeah yeah i'm not saying he's going to
do that i'm not saying he's going to do
that anytime soon but
i go right back to the beginning of our
conversation
the potential is so huge
even in a one percent allocation that is
why you should own bitcoin you have to
make the assumption the industry is
going to solve this problem and larry
will write that letter one day
and when that happens
katie bar the doors
i love it all right money show every
wednesday what is it 10 p.m eastern
it's money court on cnbc money 12
money court yes and i think you will see
yourself in these cases every family
will see themselves um i i just i think
this is i think the show is going to go
forever because you can't
stop watching it that's what happened it
just i when i was taping it and all the
all the crew which aren't supposed to
watch tv they're supposed to make tv
they were all stuck watching the line
feed monitors going
wow i mean these are gut wrenching
linux these are people that really
really are suing each other for real
money
is it
and you answer however you want but is
this kind of like a judge judy you're
kind of watching a slow car crash but
you can't turn away it just has the
seriousness of real money
and actual like financial disagreements
and then you're there uh providing kind
of uh uh decisions and insight and
guidance
no i'm i'm the ultimate decider for the
outcome they have signed a contract so
instead of going into court and
litigating and waiting for the outcome
through a court trial they're going to
wait for my outcome but i really i
listen to the federal judge on the panel
and i also listen to the trial attorney
but ultimately i try and save the
business
in next week's episode you're going to
see something very very crazy
um
a a a couple of partners that suit each
other not over failure of a business
over success
they were so successful
that they had a
a breaking up of their long-term
partnership between
doing their expansion corporately or
doing it through franchising and
they actually went after each other even
though they were the most
i've never seen a more profitable
business on a percentage of free cash
flow than this
i was blown away and i said you guys are
insane you're suing each other over this
and they were and i decided watch that
show you're going to find it interesting
anybody who's got a royalty in their
plans i know they're the winners so yeah
i appreciate it i appreciate you coming
on uh everyone make sure that you watch
money court on uh wednesday 10 p.m
eastern uh on cnbc thank you so much for
doing this and uh we're gonna do this
once a month you're gonna come on here
and you're going to uh to tell us what's
going on in the institutional world i
think it's a great idea the industry's
changing so much there's so much
happening and the regulatory environment
is getting more and more interesting i
think it's all to the upside all right
we're gonna send you a hat too so next
time you can wear a bitcoin 100k hat
perfect hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it